(mysterious music)
- I got the tooth, two.
(cute innocent music)
Let me smell your breath.
(blowing)
Let me smell it again.
(sniffing)
- Woo, yeah that's a good one alright.
- Ooo hey daddy can you
grab me some popcorn?
- [Voiceover] Got it mommy!
- We went to the beach
- [Child] Mommy.
- after that, give mommy a minute.
- Mommy needs her mommy juice.
- Water?
- Come here!
- Your spit smells.
- We have the same germs.
- Down our chimney he
sneaks into our living room
in the middle of the night.
(child crying)
What's the matter sweetie,
don't cry Santa's fun!
- Let me wiggle your tooth.
- [Child] No mommy no!
- Come on, let me, come on.
Let me see it.
- [Child] No mommy!
- It might be loose!
- Good half.
- Yeah pretty good (yells) One Direction!
- I'll have a gin double.
- Can I just get your house Chardonnay
and a wawa, do you want a wawa?
We'll have wawa for the whole table.
- I started listen to
songs, they're actually
really good, I mean some of
this stuff is like Beetle level.
I mean, did I mention I have kids?
- Yeah.
- Go, go, go yes!
You did it, give me a high-five, Woo!
That is going on Instagram.
(camera clicks)
- Ugh did I like this?
Oh no.